is still going on it's the wits tie
breaks otherwise of ruja with the white
pieces in game two against denise geary
the first one was a draw so if we have a
winner in this one that will be the
winner of the match here we go yeah here
we go farouza very very strong with the
white pieces he chooses the spanish
opening
and uh not the main line not the most
direct way of playing the spanish forum
just wants to get a position and uh play
he just wants to maneuver and all pieces
or pawns on the board that's promising
it's gonna be very tense this game
and anish yeah he just has to recover
maybe from small missed opportunity
which has been a bit of a pattern in his
games
uh so far
he just needs that confidence of a win
will this be the time black now
expanding in the center
night on the rim but that will be
re-centralized very shortly
and uh typical plan for white white
wants to re-maneuver his there we go
black's knight getting back to a good
square and white's going to maneuver his
two knights park them in front of the
white king
ah yeah i've seen pharaoh have these
types of positions
thousands of times online he loves this
especially in blitz
very easy plans for white
and anish seems to be knowing what he
did what to do as well because i saw him
give a quick nod
of his head you know he knows exactly
and he's prepared for this and uh i
don't know what i think because the
players are playing so fast and so well
prepared
we might see our first armageddon
i'm going to call it already earlier
would what do you think
it's definitely possible
i'll go white win
um
yeah i think uh
let's go for that win in the blitz game
or the armageddon simon
this one here
so uh
only because i've seen again i mean
nothing against the niche anisha is
fantastic and he obviously one of the
best prepared players in the world he
knows what he's doing here but for rouge
i've just seen him win so many as you
say david so many games in this in in
this kind of spanish position he seems
to be one of the world's if not the
world's best uh player in this type of
structure and he's and he's really good
when he gets the attack sort of going
and his pieces are heading that way now
the queen the knights might start
jumping in um so here they come so uh
so i'm going to go white win david what
about you
i would love to see armageddon uh i do
trust denise's defensive skills i know
i've been slightly critical of his uh
kind of conversion his killer instinct
but his defensive skills are good so
um yeah i mean farouza he does remind me
of bobby fischer and fisher was an
expert as well in these types of
structures with white where it's
symmetrical in the center it's kind of
this king's pawn
structure is blocked but then somehow
just maneuvering his pieces to good
squares he's very tactically sharp so
he'll seize the moment and go for it but
then again yeah a niche
so smooth as a defender uh very rarely
in trouble unless uh does anyone see a
niche winning
[Music]
so it's gone very quietly no i i i don't
see it i mean i thought maybe he could
have done it if he perhaps hadn't
gotten rid of the tension in the center
but now i
well hang on a second i quite like what
he's done there on the left you know
that pawn chain is so beautiful look at
them all lined up but of course
that's not going to decide things right
now he still has to neutralize uh every
all of farish's activity on the right
it's that big night move isn't it though
yeah it's getting ready this is the and
again i'm only saying this because of
the position and farouza i just
i when he gets attacking when he gets
near your king he's just phenomenal and
that night just looks so scary to me but
i don't know maybe
oh this is probably a good defensive
move david oh we're so fickle we're
changing our mind we're thinking oh
white's to win and then suddenly oh
black's got a nice structure and then
yeah actually ferocious attacking so
but he is the first one to land his
knight on a dangerous square black's
knight maybe a bit a bit misplaced anish
now is going to try and trade off those
nights there we go retreating white's
knight is on the dream f5 square i don't
know why it's always f5 but when a
knight gets there it's always scary for
the opposition king and ferugia says yes
you can trade off the knights
interesting decision
uh i would take those knights off in a
heartbeat now uh vanish giri he doesn't
he gives up a pawn but i don't know if
that pawn can be captured i don't think
it can because it's g5 right yeah maybe
we can very quickly show this anisha
said his nasty trap for ferocia
okay for russia doesn't trade off the
knights if he had captured a pawn here
on the edge of the board white wins a
pawn but at the very end assassin says
g5 trapped the
trap the white bishop behind enemy lines
and that piece is lost
and instead of this uh instead of this
night trade foruger decides to keep
pieces on the board but now black's
knight
finds a decent square and uh white's
knight is controlled by this pawn it's
still very tense let's go back to the
players
anything could still happen okay i don't
like the transition for white there just
the fact that the white knight is now
locked out of the game can i change my
mind again
a niche for the win
make sure you get them all in there
simon yeah yeah
just slam that knight in the middle of
the board and get the win that's all i'm
thinking but that's the cool thing about
chess at this level right it can always
shift these players yep are so good it's
happening and it's happening okay there
we go and he's for the win
seizing the ball by the horn sacrificing
a piece whoa this knight can be captured
um and maybe it will be if it isn't
we'll show what uh what would happen but
wow what a move
i think feroza missed that one i i must
i must admit i missed it as well simon
you spotted it instantly i didn't see it
at all
so uh but i mean
okay the proof is in the pudding can can
you capture that port that night yeah
maybe just while uh farouza recovers
from the shock and okay we will see it
but now after the night is captured by a
pawn
black is temporarily temporarily a piece
down but he's hitting this white bishop
and if this bishop moves no matter where
it goes to okay it does drop back
suddenly black wins the piece back and
probably with interest suddenly this is
a double attack hitting the queen
hitting the bishop as well one of
white's pieces will drop and
the thing is that the position has
opened up but in the process with that
knight jump black has won the bishop
pair and there are ideas for example of
grabbing this pawn a bit later on still
all to play for though uh still very
very complicated but the bishop pair
you've got to favor those
uh right now gary the favorite maybe now
yeah the position looks lovely for anish
and all you need to do is just mobilize
all the pieces
get them going and the rook comes and
attacks the queen
queen has to move but at the same time
has to keep an eye on defending the
bishop
so i'm predicting that the queen where's
the queen going to step back to yeah i
just it's hard to evaluate do you offer
a queen exchange normally you don't want
to take off the queens if your opponent
has the bishop power because the bishop
power will kind of grow in strength but
he'll write your anchor where else to
put the white queen
black's queen is trying to go and grab
the white pawn on the b2 square
you've got to keep that one guarded
white is temporarily a pawn up so maybe
you could make an argument for trying to
trade off the queens
so tense
and uh ferugia now lower on the clock
he's the faster player on the mouse uh i
think if it comes down to a scramble
with both sides down under 10 seconds
he's got to be a big favorite and or
favorite in the armageddon because you
don't get extra time then and he's
incredibly quick with a mouse but i mean
nietzsche is a class out you know let's
not forget that he can he can beat
anyone in the world and we usually say
right to choose the white pieces but
anish playing all these draws and he can
choose colors because he is the highest
ranked player in the tour
should he choose the black pieces i
don't think he can um if it goes down to
armageddon i think he has to take the
extra minute i've played farouja
hundreds of times online at blitz and
every time i just lose on the clock
or lose because of the clock
he's just so fast i remember one game it
was rook versus rook dead draw and he
had
he had 10 seconds i had nine seconds and
he still had nine seconds when i lost on
time he was just bang bang bang
instantly whoa um it's just you can't
keep up with him so um
i think gary has to take the time to
move that quickly it's just incredible
and well he's great he's grabbed the
pawn now as well a niche down there so
um this is a this is a dangerous bishop
though the white's got and look at the
bar look at the bar
i love it
it's going down hell though
look at the bar
[Laughter]
for a brief second there something
happened didn't it yeah why is the bar
gone down maybe they'll maybe he should
have used the other rook because queen
b6 seems like a killer idea right queen
f6 queen p6 yeah yeah you're right
is that i don't know
what have we missed here because uh just
to show it uh just while gary is
thinking here he put his queen on maybe
about a poor square and here i think
white should have used the other rook so
that the black queen doesn't have so
much choice and we'll show this in the
current position he used this rook now
at least the black queen can move either
to this square maybe it can take a pawn
uh but if it goes to the center i think
this would be a huge mistake as simon
points out this idea attacking the
bishop no matter what you do whether you
defend the bishop move it and there's
this idea and simon you mentioned
uh if you line up a queen of bishop on a
battery checkmate is inevitable here the
queen is just coming in with a checkmate
he's blundered anishkiri let's go back
to the game this is going to happen uh
the black king is in huge trouble
he just chose the wrong square with his
queen
oh dear
is there anything he can do
can he throw in an attack against the
white bishop maybe
hit it with a pawn i don't think that's
actually going to change anything can he
maybe hit it with a rook
yeah white's bishop okay he does that
jovanka white bishop is the key that
dart square diagonal pointing towards
the black king i guess you can uh just
still do that line up uh
you can get rid of the exchange then i
guess yeah maybe that's okay you need to
get rid of that white bishop at all
costs pretty much yeah uh but aneesh
okay he's banking on this fact what does
white do does white just move the bishop
oh that's calm
calm and steady wins the race
um i like that move you could maybe use
the white rook in the center lifted up
two squares attacked the black queen
so many choices farouza okay he's got a
lot of time one minute 40.
spoiled for choice now
black's position hanging by a thread we
were praising anish in just one slip and
he should have stopped this bishop
getting to this diagonal
now the bishop does stay alive
king safety you know
such an important thing
and yeah we saw magnus coulson managed
to secure a draw against levon aronian
because king safety and here is going to
torture anish gary
i'm ticking under one minute now okay
he's gonna trade a set of rooks it looks
like from his screen
okay he changes his mind
you can't really afford the time to
change your mind under one minute
getting attacked
okay he does trade rooks
okay and the still the same problem
persists how is he going to defend the
the bishop and at the same time guard
against the queen coming to the f6
square yeah dual threats two threats how
do you stop them both
you don't you just have to give
something up
and i'd rather give up the bishop than
get checkmated
if the white queen does come across to
this dark square diagonal
really tough yeah
okay
this threatens the white rook
very sneaky there i think black's
intention if the white queen comes
across was to actually give up the black
queen at some point but white's rook now
tucked away nice and safe
still the same dilemma how do you come
back no no you can come back
and uh he's managed to do it so perhaps
this wasn't the most accurate
continuation from ferrugia did you see
ferrugia suddenly leaned forward as if
he missed that move he thought he was
winning on the spot
and uh game on game
yeah yeah i like it yeah suddenly white
can't check mate white's queen and
bishop can line up on this dark square
diagonal but black can block that
uh now that the black queen is defending
okay he does go one pawn up for roger
he's still the favorite
and
however that defensive effort from anish
did cost him a lot of time and now
he has nearly a 50-second deficit over
and
over alireza yeah also when pawns are
just on one side of the board knights
tend to be a bit better than bishops uh
black's bishop will just be staring down
at some white pawns which i guess are
going to be quite well defended soon
white's knight will be flexible to jump
jump around on dark and light squares uh
so this one i think with best play
should still be very good for white but
okay for for roger he hasn't won it yet
gary's
defending super well we praised his
defensive skills earlier
and uh still 30 seconds down on the
clock
rearranging his bishop putting it on a
different diagonal
white does have double g pawns maybe
losing some flexibility there but at
least all the pawns are protected now
do you swap the queens off or not i mean
the question is because you might be
able to swap them off here by moving
your queen to square fours but it's a
bit of a tough ending that yeah with the
knight as you said david the knight this
is where the knight's better than the
bishop when the pawns are all on one
side of the board five seconds five
seconds okay he goes for a check
that's a very safe square now a threat
on the board black's queen wants to hit
the king from another angle from the h
file
and uh a check from verusa both queens
are just trying to
find their dream squares i like what
ferrous has done there just uh defending
everything
and uh okay
pushing forward he's got a really strong
idea now if that white knight can jump
into the jump into the position that
he'll be winning um so
he can't quite do it can he push the
pawn to f4 and then do it there's a
question
yeah i mean that that looks tactically
like yeah a killer blown he's done it
simon it's a family fork isn't it
if you can just pick up that white
knight plant it on f6 in an end game in
the current position anywhere that white
knight on f6 will just win the game
and even here you can probably exchange
queens if you want to a very promising
position but
more it's also tempting just to go
forward with your pawns yeah for forward
destabilize the black king
that a little bit more okay and it's on
the board
yeah those are two very scary pawns
those two white pawns marching forward
black's king now also slightly opened up
and uh
it's okay 10 seconds
it has to take some quick decisions time
is ticking
anything could still happen yeah yeah
yeah absolutely anisha's fighting so
hard
all credit to him for great defense yeah
finding ways against the master of
attack to
stick in the game but i'm i i don't know
i'm not sure he can uh well look at this
he's getting he's getting some decent
counter play here i mean the bishop is
very good and look at the pawn the pawn
is just running
and uh you know if the queen's come off
now he's gonna win the central pawn and
uh yeah this is uh this is this should
be absolutely fine for black yeah he
should be able to draw this now but it
was just the speed suddenly giri upped
his speed bang bang bang and he was up
on the clock there ferrule went down to
two seconds
if that's what you got to do and blitz
it's about when to change the momentum
when to pick up the pace and the queen's
coming off yeah like you said simon
getting rid of that white central pawn
was the key white's h pawn alone
shouldn't be enough to win this game and
that's a nice move cutting off the white
rook
uh from the defense of its pawn
and the black king is coming do you
think gary's trying to win this game
i think the king can take one step
forward right yeah why not you know and
uh
probably at drawers they're probably a
draw rook and bishop do combine better
than rooker knight
usually
uh so right now white's king as well
caught in a mating net
look for russia i can barely talk it's
so tense yeah i mean black shouldn't be
worse over the coordination of his three
pieces in the center of the board
i mean i i think ferruccio should be
taking the draw he's going for it he's
trying to repeat the position and there
we go we're going to get our first
armageddon of the tournament oh we love
it
in five minutes
armageddon to decide this match between
aneesh giri and ali reza faruja anish
giri